[Music]
all right we're gonna go to new haven
connecticut with miguel hey miguel how
are you
good thank you how are you great what's
going on
thank you for taking my call sure uh
so i am
about to be 37 years old and uh
i'm finding myself in a pretty
overwhelming situation
uh i've got
about five hundred thousand dollars in
debt
that has uh
accumulated it comes a it's a mix of irs
debt
uh student loans credit cards and auto
loan
and uh
i'm making 87 000 a year
on my
income and
about 17.50 a month on disability
uh
so i'm finding myself in a situation now
where
it's all kind of
falling on my lap
i just put together my very first budget
at 36 years old
using the every dollar app and i'm
coming up short um
i'm not really sure where to go from
here so
i looked into bankruptcy chapter 7
chapter 13
and i got off the phone with a law
agency uh earlier today they said that i
would probably qualify for chapter uh 13
um but my income i guess is too high uh
for chapter seven
um
so i'm just kind of looking for some
guidance uh looking to see what my best
option would be
uh where i could get some
free advice uh if there's any
um
see where to go from here yeah i'm so
sorry all right i can hear
yeah
are you are you married have kids
overwhelming yeah uh so i have one child
uh i'm divorced
and uh i've been through two separations
which have you know they've kind of led
me to this situation financially um
so yeah i got a little bit on my plate
well yeah what do you what do you do for
a living
i am a nurse practitioner okay awesome
so currently i'm in a residency program
and they're only paying 87 000 a year
because i'm in a learning phase this is
a one year program
after this if i decide to stay at the va
i'll go up to about 110 thousand
uh if i decide to go outside of the va
i will make more money but uh in the end
i'll lose you know retirement benefits
and and you know free healthcare for
life everything that comes with being a
federal employee so that's another
question whether i should continue to
work at the va and bank on those
benefits
or you know seek employment elsewhere
and try to make as much money as fast as
i can
so what i would tell you is um you're
drowning right and you know that right
yes
um
here's here's the analogy that might not
be perfect but the analogy you just gave
me is i want to stay in the water
because i've got this life raft here
versus i'm going to start swimming to
shore and i'm going to get out of the
water completely
and what feels safe long term eventually
if you will
may ultimately sink you because you're
you don't have enough money here this
makes me happy that you're in a one-year
program okay because you're gonna at
least double your salary and absolutely
you're gonna get out of the va and go
out to the open market and work
and you're gonna be able to
being a nurse practitioner man you're
gonna be able to make a great salary
and you're gonna have to just start
slowly grinding this thing away and you
feel like you're 100 years old you're
not you're absolutely not
um
what you said you got disability what's
your disability from are you a veteran
i am okay from my time overseas awesome
um
so you've got disability on top of your
87
uh correct yes okay uh total
growth income
is 108.
okay all right great so
the chances of you coming out of here
and getting 160 or 170
what's that what's what's the
feasibility in your market
uh
i mean if i were to take travel
contracts like a local tenant position
yep i could probably get that there
would be you know multiple short-term
contracts which i've done as an rn
uh to make ends meet you know with the
covet crisis there you go
um i'd probably do the same thing as a
nurse practitioner
so what i want you to step back and look
and say okay 37 i'm gonna be 38 when i'm
out of this program here
if i put myself on a four and a half or
five year plan
and i worked backwards
what kind of contracts would i have to
take over the four and a half to five
years and will you be tired absolutely
you're gonna be exhausted
but what would it look like to pay this
debt off settle some of this with the
irs if you can settle some of this with
your credit card company if you can you
can't settle those student loans your
those are just weights you're gonna have
to tread water with
what would it look like
what would i have to earn to be able to
reverse engineer this and my guess is at
150 160 175 000
this becomes a lot more surmountable
with if you've got a plan you're
experiencing christine's beginning of
this you're experiencing miguel with so
many folks and whether it's 500 000 or
50 000
is that initial shock when you see a
budget and you think oh no this is
forever and i want you to know it's not
but it's a matter of these baby steps as
you walk and walk and walk and you've
got a pacifier with the feds and you're
going to have to let that go
and you're going to have to work like
you thought you were busy when you were
younger in the ser you're going to have
to work like you haven't worked
but man at that salary at that level
you've got a big shovel you'll be able
to dig out of this quicker than you
think and just and the key to this is
while while you're making good money and
you've put in the work to do this
residency and all those things it's
going to be really tempting to be like
well i deserve xyz you've got to live on
nothing
the the more you live on nothing rice
and beans means the rice i mean you get
creative with every possible thing that
you can to keep your expenses to an
absolute minimum
for a season the more you can live on
nothing and get that income up like
we're talking about the faster you're
out of debt and so you absolutely can do
this and one of the things that um
i want to make sure that we give you
miguel if you'll stay on the line i'll
have kevin
kelly give you a membership a year
membership to ramsey plus which it has
our class in there called financial
peace university
and you watch these lessons and here's
what's going to be so key it's not only
going to show you how to get out of debt
it's going to keep you motivated on the
journey there's an incredible community
in there as well and you can connect
with those people you can get
inspiration get encouragement get
teaching you'll also have that budgeting
app that we're talking about which will
sync with your bank so watch those
lessons and do exactly like john said
we've got to get the income up to be
able to get out of this mess but you can
do it and once you can see the plan then
you'll see how you can do it so can i
tell you this miguel we just had a
couple in a previous hour on today's
show do a debt-free screen
and
they paid off five hundred thousand
dollars
oh man what they say they got they got
after it
they got after it in in five years yes
and right after he was diagnosed he was
diagnosed with um with a parkinson's
parkinson's and so i'm gonna tell you i
just had somebody stand in front of us
on the debt-free stage and they did it
okay
here's another thing i want you to
remember um tell me about your little
one
uh she's nine years old nine years old
she loves to sing that's awesome so
listen to me
this stops with you
because in five years
how you said she's nine years old
she's nine yeah nine years old right in
five years she's gonna be 14.
and she's gonna have a debt-free dad who
walks about seven inches taller than he
is right now
and she's gonna skip to have a ringside
seat to sacrifice to hard work
to hey we don't have the money to go to
disneyland so we're going camping
we're gonna sorry we're going fishing
we're gonna figure this stuff out we're
going to hang out with uncle so-and-so
and aunt so-and-so and they live in this
crazy town and she's going to have a
ringside seat to adventure and sacrifice
and she's going to get to watch her
family tree change
while she's in it
and it's because your sacrifice is not
going to go unnoticed so brother you're
about to change your family tree and
your daughter's never going to
experience this and your why goes way
past this scary moment right now
your legacy her legacy and her kids
legacy brother so congratulations and
you call us back when you're debt-free
and you're going to do that debt-free
scream on this stage absolutely with us
and we're going to celebrate you because
you're going to do it and i can't wait
to watch you do it awesome thanks for
calling miguel